everybody was hooking up with everybody
dude Adrian it's been 20 years since
driving me crazy yes it has jealous
what do you remember most about that oh
just so much fun with that whole cat it
was such a big cast of so many people my
age whereas I was used to working on I
mean Sabrina we had a lot of people my
age
Clarissa we only had the two boys so
anytime I get to work with peers it's
awesome and especially in that movie it
was just we were shooting in Utah Adrian
I remember doing the I was doing it I I
had I had the role of Nicole but we were
trying to find who was gonna play chase
and so we did a screen test together and
I was just thinking this guy's this
guy's good like he's deep and he's gonna
push me to be better I don't know if I
want to work with him but it was so
great to like I was working with an
acting coach we he and I were running
the scenes together constantly and just
like really taking my craft seriously
for the first time I feel like yeah and
just having those kids around and just
being able to play in Utah a little bit
you know just having fun on the set
everybody was hooking up with everybody
you know not being Adrian Adrian and Ali
Larter but really me and a guy named
Gabriel Carpenter who played the boy I
was chasing him yeah the table wanted a
tall guy Wow very tall men
how funny yeah you heard that right Jim
Melissa Joan Hart filling major hook-up
secrets from the set tub driving me
crazy
the actress also has a lot to say about
working with this iconic pop star
also the music video was so iconic what
do you remember about working with
Britney she and I were crossing paths a
lot at the time she came in and did a
bit on Sabrina and because of the movie
we had to do a lot of press together we
were doing a lot of like we hosted TRL
together and stuff like that so there
was a lot of us meeting up in random
states around the country and random
events but also with like in sync and
Backstreet Boys and all those people at
the time um you know was always fun to
run into friendly faces and she and I
became friendly and we had a little bit
of an age difference and I was always
trying to break her out of she was very
protected by a lot of people and I was
always trying to be like you need to let
loose you're like 17 and he does not be
always like in the gym working doing
your Pepsi commercials doing the videos
doing you know like let's go out and go
dancing so like why she loved that I
think maybe a little too much you think
are you surprised then with everything
going on right now with her family and
stuff I don't really know I don't know
the ins and outs because we haven't kept
in touch in decades but I did go to her
Vegas show a few years ago to meet up
there and completed you and we're yeah
yeah and we're we're both moms now you
know and we are in a new stage of our
careers and just interesting just you
know kind of seeing I wish we had gotten
time to just kind of sit and talk but it
was like real quick she's going onstage
you know I feel like the stories that
you guys could probably go back and
remember and tell and you guys could
have your little ones having I know I
would love to catch up with her at some
point but we just have these busy
different lines yes we can only hope for
that Melissa Britney reunion another
blast from Melissa's past Clarissa
explains it all
I loved Clarissa yeah there were lots of
talks of a reboot yeah what's um there
was a weird stall out Nickelodeon was
flirting with the idea and I think there
was a script I was there a script
written or an outline or something but
Nickelodeon the executives changed over
there and
kind of got kind of like pushed to the
backburner for a minute so I'm not
really sure I don't know what happened
is that something you would still like
to revisit it depends if it was done
right yeah but um I don't really want to
be just the mom on a kids show it would
have to be like Nickelodeon it would be
a kids show you know so I feel like it
should be a little bit more like fleabag
honestly they be not quite that but you
know that's where I wish Clarissa had
like ten years later gone was that kind
of place yeah and I think that's exactly
where should probably well I think she
might owes but for now Melissa's gearing
up to release her new lifetime Christmas
movie coming out on November 2nd
don't didn't like Tahoe where I live
right now so it was awesome because we
had snow until June
so it actually snowed a few days on the
set it was kind of awesome but yeah we
get to build snowmen and drink cocoa by
the fire and we have a dog in this one
it was really fun we had a fantastic
cast such fun people to play with and
you play an event planner I'm an event
planner but my dad and I basically run
the inn okay and everybody shows up for
the holidays yeah and yeah so I'm in
charge of like you know the gingerbread
house making and the snowman making and
we go skiing and stuff so I actually got
to ski in this movie which was really
fun but I actually don't know camera
know I but we had to do this scene when
we're on a lift and I kept wanting to
ski down so we take the lift up Ricardo
couldn't ski so you take the lift back
around and I would ski down and they're
like well we'll turn the camera around
and get you but like twice I did it and
they didn't get it and I was like I'm
not doing it yeah like you had time shot
and now I'm gonna like break my leg in
the middle of a shot and not finish the
movies oh right right do your kids just
love that you get to do these holiday
Christmas with them they've been in a
lot they're not in this one okay but
they have been in a bunch of them so
very nutty Christmas last year and the
year before that very merry toys story
yeah they have a few lines and they show
up once in a while you might see them
is it fun for you to watch them sort of
wanting to follow in your footsteps do
your resume yes I have reservations I
know they they want to do it for all the
wrong reasons you know they think it's
easy they think they'll be rich all
these things Instagram followers yeah
that kind of stuff well luckily my kids
are not not in they don't have devices
so they're there they've state I've kept
them far away yeah stuff but as long as
I can but they yeah they just like they
like it because they're fascinated by it
sort of but not enough like not in a way
that's like they haven't picked up on
the creativity part of it yeah you know
so you know my oldest one wants to be an
NFL player which then he thinks will
fund the airplane company he wants to
study want to be like Richard Branson he
also started so he wants to be a pilot
and start his own airline and you know
the middle one probably still wants to
be an astronaut and the little one it
was probably gonna be some sort of
serial killer I'm not sure if you're
dreaming how do you balance everything
keep a really good calendar really good
schedule okay you know making sure my
husband sees everything too like today
my son has Mandarin class and the other
one has to go to basketball game and
yeah I'm sorry are you raising genius no
not no they're you know they're they
just they like what they like and you
want to encourage that you know his
friends were all learning a language in
sixth grade but he had moved to a
different school and he was like well I
choose Mandarin can you get me a
Mandarin as I killed some remembrance
he's like sometime when we go to the
Great Wall mom I'm gonna translate for
you like alright you got it
do you know I don't know no I I'm the
one that's learning Italian he's
learning Mandarin oh this is learning
French and the little ones learning
Spanish so we're trying to cover all our
bases cuz we love to travel that's
amazing dinners fun at your house I bet
being thrown around we're like we're
like spaghetti being around that's
amazing
do you speak Italian I've been studying
it for Fears trying to but it's it's
hard yeah it's so nerve-wracking like
trying to if anyone's like Oh speak
Italian oh my god
I don't know what to say say we should
watch your movie but in Italian I'll say
my name Miki amo Melissa let's honor
[Music]